welcome back this gentleman who coaches
one of the three remaining undefeated
teams through three weeks in the
National Football League as a matter of
fact his team has a full two-game lead
on the rest of the AFC East and that
includes the team that they are gonna be
facing by visiting this week in the New
England Patriots he is the head coach of
the Miami Dolphins Adam GaSe how are you
coach I'm great how you doing I'm doing
just fine three and OH
right now and how does one continue
winning football games in the National
Football League after starting as well
as you do what is that what would be the
plan on something like that are they
really the biggest thing for us is just
resetting every week realizing whatever
happened in the past we have to learn
from it and focus on the task at hand
which is you know the next opponent that
we have for the following week and
checking in with players to see if
they're reading any clips or anything
like that are you having to give any
messages on that front I think I think
our biggest message that we really try
to explain to our players is don't don't
read in it anything we try to we do the
best we can as far as trying to keep
guys off Twitter and Instagram it's
never going to happen but you know just
reading anything that's negative
positive it really doesn't matter it
swings from week to week to the NFL is
is it feels like you're in a different
sport I'd be like 10 10 games in
baseball so you just you have to stay
focused with what you're doing and it's
just the swings are just too great yeah
it is amazing how how things as you
point out things can totally change for
instance nobody gave a team in your
division in the Bills a chance at all
after week one in less than 14 days
later they take care of the Minnesota
Vikings how much are you going to rely
on what you did against the Patriots
last time you faced them on that Monday
night contest last year and employ this
week coach I think we're we're two two
different teams at least we as far as
well as far as I'm talking about what
we're just different compared to what we
were last year I think they've made some
as well to where you know they're doing
a few different things and they're doing
some of their same same things that
they've done on defense in the past but
there's a no different guy calling it
and there's a different different flavor
and offensively you know they got
different targets and players that
they're working with so I think it's so
early in the season where we're both
really trying to really get find our way
to figuring out who we're gonna be
long-term both both teams so it it takes
time to really establish who you're
going to be throughout the season and
you know this being the fourth week of
the season I think we're both still
trying to feel that out well let's let's
walk through the season so far with you
coach case I mean week one I've never
you know seen a game having done the NFL
Network thing for sure over the last 15
years 16 seasons I've never seen a game
with to weather delays as long as the
one that you went through how in the
world were you keeping your guys
mentally ready still physically ready
twice during that day and that week one
went over the Titans well I think we
were all convinced there was just going
to be one so who in that first one we
were really talking about what was going
to happen from then on out we knew where
there was going to be a shorter halftime
so we weren't coming back in so we were
really doing a lot of our halftime
adjustment type things in that in that
time frame and they kept pushing the
time back which that was probably more
frustrating for our players I mean as a
coach we're able to keep discussing
things that happened already in the game
so you're afforded more time which isn't
a bad thing we did kind of felt like we
were turning a corner in that game when
when they kind of had that first break I
mean it was it was pretty steamy out it
was the temperature was up there and we
were certain moving the ball a little
bit we're hoping to use that to our
advantage and that kind of became a
disadvantage for us we gave them a
chance to recover and regroup and you
know the second one was they told us
right away it was going to be a while
and it was really a game guys off their
feet
you know a lot of guys were you know
grabbing something to eat
we had thankfully we had some a lot of
food down down there in lockers where
guys could really not just lose all
their energy and we we had plenty of
things for them to eat down there so
nobody put a moving on that's what
you're saying nobody just flipped on the
tube no that's like no what we did we
didn't do that but I felt like guys did
a good job there was there kind of
hanging out in groups and in talking
football and and really just trying to
just to say focus on what we had to do
we that was the biggest thing we just
wanted to make sure that we figured out
a way to win that game and I think guys
were really really into doing what was
right and just stay focused what we're
doing and then there's week two a road
trip in Division two the Jets fresh off
of Sam Darnell doing what he did on
Monday Night Football and everybody got
caught up in that and when I say
everybody I mean in the national media
I've raised my hand saying I got caught
up in all of that as well
and you went in and put the bang thing
on that kid what what did you see out of
Darnell knowing that you perhaps might
be seeing him quite a bit over the next
several years coach well well being his
first home game and and we knew it was
gonna be the crowd was going to be
lively and loud and it was going to be a
great atmosphere to play in and like
their guys stayed focused on what we
were trying to do which was create
pressure on him try to stay as tight as
we could coverage wise you know he moved
the ball there was times where they were
moving the ball well and we were able to
get a few turnovers and we got a we got
a good jump as far as a short field I'm
one of them and we put it in the end
zone and then we were up 20 to nothing
there a halftime and then they really
put the Klan's down on us on on defense
in the second half and then they started
moving the balls ball and we had a you
know they had a chance to really price
swing that game and Xavier Howard made
probably one of the better interceptions
that I've ever seen and you know that
really helped to at least call him
everything down for us and it was a
battle for the next quarter and a half
and then you come home and you fall down
early to Oakland and Tannehill was
terrific
I mean he had one of his best games
maybe
as a professional what have you seen in
Ryan Tannehill a coach that made you
want to stick with him stick with him
throughout his knee injury stick with
him coming back from it what what what
what do you see in Ryan Tannehill that
you have been able to glean and use
successfully well I think he you know he
he has the physical traits and that's
that's fairly obvious if you if you
watch him play but I mean this guy is
tough smart and he cares about his
teammates he wants to make sure that he
does everything he can to make sure he's
prepared our offense is prepared and and
that he gives us an opportunity to score
points and put us in position to win
games and I think guys appreciate that
you know we look through a lot of
adversity last year and I think him
being gone really a lot of our guys that
were here they they appreciated him you
know for all the things that he had done
before he was injured and then when he
came back yet you could see there was
you could see and feel something a
little different when he when he got
back to where he was here for one reason
that was one football games and you know
he throws numbers and all those types of
things aside his goal is to win and and
try to get as many guys involved as
possible and distribute the ball and you
know he wants to get a lead for this
defense so that they can go do what they
do well which is past Russian you know
he's done that and he's you know his
attitude you can tell he's he missed it
you know being gone for that year he he
loves being out there he competes
extremely hard in games he's fearless in
the pocket and sometimes too fearless
well on the move but you know that's if
that's my biggest complaint I think I
can live with that one Adam GaSe
Dolphins head coach here on the Rich
Eisen show and you've worked with
quarterbacks absolutely everywhere
you've been and you just gave voice to
the value of Ryan Tannehill and the
value that this franchise places in him
so it's interesting that in this day and
age where we're seeing more and more
roughing the passer calls than ever
before based on the new emphasis on a
rule about placing body weight on to a
quarterback that it appears you are the
first head coach in the NFL to have a
player blowout as knee attempting to not
a body weight on top of a coach and
William Hayes I wonder what goes through
your mind when you see that coach well I
didn't know it at the time we we really
didn't know it was it was a very odd way
that he came down and at first I don't
think anybody thought was thinking ACL
and you know when we finally got the MRI
and all that stuff back and found out
about it that was that was that was
heartbreaking for us because he's one of
our leaders he's he's one of those guys
that does all the dirty work and doesn't
look for the any kind of the glory or
praise he just he does he quietly and
guys respect him and he he was really
one you know probably what our main you
know run stopper and he has been since
he's been here and he brings a brought
an element to work to our defense that
you know work we'll miss and you know
we're gonna have to have the next man up
mentality which everybody knows but it
still it's still hard to it's a hard
pill to swallow losing a guy like that
well in the manner in which you lost him
though do you do you think this rule is
needs to be changed on the spot it seems
like everybody's going to start getting
together in the competition committee to
discuss it would you be up for this rule
being changed at least in terms of the
emphasis it's hard for it's hard for me
to say one way or the other rich because
I don't want to I don't know all the
everything that's happened you know when
you when you're in the middle season you
don't really you don't see everything
and you don't hear everything because
you're kind of kind of in a bomb shelter
almost you know so you know I just I
know it's unfortunate what happened argh
I just really really stings I didn't
really realize that's what he was trying
to do when it happened and when I found
out afterwards that that was I was
frustrating for me to hear I
I appreciate that he was trying to do
the right thing and in you know play by
the rules and I just hate losing a guy
like that over something that you know
probably could have been avoided what if
I paid your fine coach what if I paid
your fine no I'm not looking to anger
anybody has frustrating that that
happened and
when is that when it's a guy that's
that's key to your defense you know and
we lost a few guys that that during that
game so that was pictures but it's a
tough one that we can look well I'm glad
you didn't accept it I really wasn't
willing to do that just so you
understand you know just throwing that
out there before I let you go Frank Gore
what what in the world is he brought
here he is unbelievable this guy to me
deserves a jacket one day that's gold I
think he's gonna get it you've got a
you've got a dynamic kid in Kenyan Drake
but it seems that Frank's getting the
ball a lot so far coach what has he
brought to your team well I've always
been a fan of using multiple grind
action it's a long season and the way
that we use Kenyan is is a little
different than a lot of teams are able
to use running backs because he is he's
unique and you know if it was up to him
he'd be playing special teams too and we
obviously can't afford that because of
the value that he brings with with our
offense and I think him and Frank are a
great one-two punch and I love what
Frank's brought when the day's been here
he's such a pro he works probably as
hard or harder than anybody that I've
ever been around he he practices like
it's a game when when when we have ego
you know we we only really practice them
on Wednesdays and then on Fridays he
does a little bit but we don't we don't
try to do too much we the way we look at
it as Frank's got enough reps in his
career we really don't need to to wear
him out more than that he already really
does and you know he's he's rare I don't
know if there's really a lot of guys
that I've ever even been around that are
close to pro as that guy and you know we
actually wrote up the names that are in
front of them on on a board one day and
it's unbelievable to think that Emmitt
Smith Walter Payton and Barry Sanders
were only three guys inside of them I
just shows what what an amazing career
he's had so far here I'm plus one on
that one coach hey thanks for the call
we appreciate it hope oh this is not the
only time we get to speak to you
throughout the season iris just make
sure that you keep your trend of not
taking us Susie I knew you were going to
go
you know Adam GaSe I knew I just sensed
it I knew we were gonna go in that
direction you must have missed week one
NFL gameday morning when I was the only
one on the panel that thought that you
would beat the Tennessee Titans I must
admit well we'll have to go to video go
to that cuz I'm gonna question that
excuse me sir and the eye thing though
it's things even more though that that
mooch incurred to guys that that are
supposed to be champions and fan club
are constantly taking against us
you know what again the eye on the sky
of week one will not lie when you check
that tape and I am more than happy to
provide a link to you and the rest of
the staff there yeah wait too weak to I
gotta be honest with you I'm from New
York City as you know I got caught up in
the darn old mania I got caught up in it
and I think that video probably landed
on your desk I totally get it
week three Musburger came on here and
said he'd like the Raiders and I I've
seen Mia culpa so what if you do you
want me to choose you this week is that
what you're saying no no what happened I
think I saw I think I saw week two
I miss all week three that ya feel like
herb was the only one that picked us
that's true that is correct
Irv was the only one who picked you week
three but week one I was there for you
and I saw you I think I was getting
ready again I had my poncho on exactly
alright coach thanks again for for being
on the show and clearly keeping an eye
on things I appreciate it all right back
atcha that's Adam GaSe coach of the
Miami Dolphins here on the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience